hey everyone welcome to another google+
hangout i'm super excited to have josh
Felber with me he is running a show on
the whatever it takes network and asked
to interview me we're going to talk
about success and I thought he why don't
we doing on my hangups you guys feeling
more about josh as well and so this is
going to be Josh's show so Josh over to
you buddy awesome Evan I really
appreciate it sorry I do a quick intro
here just for the show itself and then
we'll get into everything welcome back I
am Josh Felder on whatever it takes
network and you're watching making bank
and i'm so excited today we are here
with Evan Carmichael super serial
entrepreneur like myself and uh Twitter
extraordinaire and I'm excited to have
him on the show today to be able to
share with you guys some awesome tips on
how to supercharge your business how to
take your business to the next level and
dirt and alert a little bit more about
Evan and what he's done to create
success around his entrepreneurial life
welcome Evan thanks for having me Josh
pleasure for sure so I guess you know I
some of my audience may be familiar with
your son may not be but I'd like to kind
of get a little bit of background on you
know I know you sold a business and you
know you're just into focus on helping
other entrepreneurs grow their
businesses and maybe just give everybody
a quick overview what your background
how you got started and were you how you
got to where you are today yeah so super
quick I started when I was 19 I had a
biotech software company with two
partners and and we sucked hard uh uh
you know I'm making three hundred
dollars a month like I turned down
high-paying jobs and and I'm you know
supposed to be live in the entrepreneur
life and all my friends are jealous of
me and Here I am like can't afford to do
anything but eat beans for lunch and I
was of course to you know too proud to
let them know I was just saying yeah I'm
brining it i'm working hard we're
killing it meanwhile we were just dying
and eventually turned it around and we
can get into that store if you want
later but ended up getting customers and
countries including not johnson Johnson
and NASA / course of three years and
then sold my business went into the
venture capital gain for a couple years
learn about other financing and then
started my new business which is helping
entrepreneurs and I have a popular
website popular YouTube channel
everything I will try to do now is at
scale so i want to be able to help you
know millions of entrepreneurs at a time
for sure awesome and so I guess what
from your business that you had being in
the biotech and you know and you sound
like you guys usually turned it around
your being you know what gave you in
Canada with it was that switch that made
you transition over like hey you know
I'm gonna get out I want to be able to
help and get back to you you can help
other entrepreneurs grow their business
uh that's which came it wasn't like I
wish I could say had it all planned out
it wasn't all planned out when i sold my
company it was great it was a great high
like yeah i sold my business but then
also depressing and that i didn't know
what to do next juror and I just
honestly just explored a whole bunch of
things and one of them was the ymca
asked me to come and speak to their
group of entrepreneurs and put on a free
event to help mentor them and I said
sure why not happy to kind of give back
and get some advice right now they put
on this free event and they're promoted
to their audience and i was i quoted two
people that I knew and spent like weeks
putting together my best you know
information and I get to the day and I'm
nervous my palms are sweating I hadn't
done any public speaking my heart's
beating I go to the room and only three
people showed up to this event Oh in my
my heart you know stop a thing for a
second there and but the show must go on
you like those three people came and I
thought I did this work i'm gonna go i'm
gonna help these three people yeah it
was awesome like I really helped those
three people by telling my story and
giving them advice and they left kind of
different people than what they came in
hey and I didn't know how is ever going
to make money doing this but it just
felt so good that I knew I had to find a
way to keep going so that was that was
it start it was just exploring and then
fire that I love awesome not as really
cool
and then to now than what you do is you
you consult for businesses is that kind
of what the focus is or I know if you
don't you have your YouTube channel and
your blog and everything but is it more
beyond that or you just kind of focus on
driving content you know for people
there i do but it's got to be i scale I
basically want to I almost quit I almost
failed like I was this close I told my
partner I quit you know and so many
entrepreneurs quick and by making a few
simple changes i was able to get my
business to grow and i wanted to share
that with other people so they didn't
have to go through all the suffering
that I went through and so I really
might try to do now is that scale so you
know doing this show with Josh felber
reaching news of entrepreneurs that's
what's up I do my youtube channel work
on a book deal so I do do some work with
entrepreneurs but again I don't do like
one-on-one consulting much it's more
your scale doesn't actually for me
that's right always been its kind of
that 101 feel like you're talking about
and it does because not time consuming a
bad way but just the fact that you're
limited on the amount of people that
you're able to reach and touch and help
and so that's one of the things for me
is over the last six to eight months
I've been transitioning everything from
that one on one more one mastermind
larger type scale you know presents and
working with people as well as the show
so that we were able to help a lot of
people that way and I've had some
awesome people like yourself on so I
love it huh cool so uh what dumb from
working you know with you know in your
businesses and then the content you've
pushed out and I did you see a lot of
people responding to your content Irving
you know whether I guess maybe three
highlights or something that you can
pull as teaching points and say hey guys
here's you know what I've seen you know
as you're growing your business yours
three major hurdles that you may come
across and how to overcome those sure
number one the second is probably the
most cliched but it's do something
you're passionate about and I see so
many entrepreneurs just start a business
because they're trying to make money the
cheese awesome opportunity that and they
have no interest in that business really
they don't they don't live it
don't breathe it they don't sleep it
like you gotta love what you're doing to
a crazy extent because as soon as you
face some minor hurdle you're going to
give up because you don't love it you
just feel cheese some other
opportunities if you look at the people
who built massive businesses had
tremendous success is because they
really love what they did so love what
you do pretty simple but most people
don't do it right the second one I guess
would be model success and this is what
helps save my business understanding
that whatever problem you're facing
right now whatever goal you're trying to
achieve it's already been solved you
know you don't have to be the genius a
club with everything yourself whatever
you try to do find someone who's already
done it and modeled their success that's
what saved my business when I was a 19
year old software entrepreneur you know
sucking making no money I hit the bottom
and I then discovered hey you know what
I'm at the first guy that kind of sale
software before like this can't be that
hard there's got to be something I'm
missing when someone who's had success
and I'm modeled Bill Gates who started
Microsoft awesome and not how Bill Gates
makes it extra million dollars now right
i mean i don't care about that but 0 to
1 right like 01 that's what i want to do
how do i do it come on Bill Gates give
me some answers ah and he didn't work
partnerships but yeah partnerships was
his strategy Microsoft was all built
through partnering up with bigger
companies her big deal with ride me out
sure but before IBM there were already
sub million dollar company and seven
million is not not huge but it's still
seven million more than I had and they
got there through partnerships and so I
started forming my first partnership and
that first check came in was 13 and a
half thousand dollars and I was just I
wanted to crop it like that may not
sound like a lot of money they're going
from zero but what you're eating beans
you know when you're celebrating wins
with McDonald's french fries 300 bucks a
month that thirteen and a half que ellos
ellas gold reserve and more importantly
it gave me a strategy to keep using over
and over and over and over again and
some model success like stop trying to
come with every single idea yourself
just like you're doing on this show
right you're interviewing people who had
success trying to pull out clues and
your audience can model that success to
hopefully improve their business in
their lives excellent evett we gotta
take a quick break when we come back I
love the finish up with point three and
touch a little more detail on those I
have Josh felber you're watching making
bank on the Weber it takes network and
we're here with Evan Carmichael we'll be
right back cool I give it a minute and
we'll fire right back up all right good
we got we're bringing energy today yeah
for sure man all right guys I am Josh
builder you're watching making bank on
the whatever it takes network and I'm
excited to be back we're speaking with
Evan Carmichael and he's been driving
dropping some awesome nuggets of wisdom
on three different highlight points that
he's seen or he's utilized in his
businesses to grow and be able to scale
and just start to you know make money to
deliver value you know to his clients
there anything so Evan we'd wrapped up
with number two about modeling other
businesses you talked about how you
model the Microsoft in the software
field and I think we're just getting
ready to jump into point number three
and you know what was that next step
yeah so number one was follow your
passion number two with model success
and number three is do you and I think
this is uh this is a huge problem for a
lot of entrepreneurs because there's a
lot of ways to have success in business
there's a ton of ways have success in
business and you've got to find the one
that fits your personality best do what
makes you come alive and what you really
good at and want to learn more at right
so as an example I'm a terrible
networker ah it may not come across you
know I'm a really introverted guy in
general you know I'm not the guy hanging
up my business card on an airplane and
and you know strikeout conversation
that's not me right and so if my
business depending on me doing that I
would fail I mean I have to go get a job
but I found a different way to stand
right instead I kick up a ton of noise
is in my field I'm putting out YouTube
videos and I'm really active on Twitter
and my goal is instead of just going to
events and being a
guess there and trying to make
connections I want to speak at the
events okay you get people to come and
network with me afterwards right and so
that's me right and so you may hear lots
of big strategies and you can try them
and see if they work but you've got to
find the ones that best fit who you are
and your personality and too many
entrepreneurs try to improve their
witnesses is the first on their
strengths like if you suck at something
don't go all in trying to get better at
it you're not going to like it you're
not going to get really good at it and
if you're never going to be a happy
entrepreneur successful instead if you
don't like it stop it go all in on what
you're really good at cuz that's where
you're going to really create a lot of
value definitely I think that's a huge
for uses I know am I don't you know
working with entrepreneurs and you know
just being some different events and
things you see or be like oh this person
and this is the way they're doing it and
you're so awesome at it and then they
try to do it they're just man you're
miserable and and they're like well how
are they doing it but I can't you know
and it's definitely you got to find what
fits you really well and and then
utilize that strength to grow and I mean
that's that's an awesome thing I think
you so many there are a lot of people
that are introverted and like how do I
get out network and you're like I'll
just make the people come talk to me
nice going and speaking Thea that so
that's very you know just a genius way
to go about and that's awesome yeah and
we all have these things that we wish we
could be better at and and so many
people just they get so disappointed and
and so frustrated and so upset trying to
make their weaknesses better like if you
suck at networking don't go out and try
to get better and then working you'll
just be disappointed unhappy you will be
getting results find another way to do
it like don't let that be the only way
to achieve success there's tons of other
ways funny one that works for you for
sure awesome pic and I think just some
great information that you know ads
Oxford yeah we can take and you know be
able to utilize all three of those
points to really ramp up our business to
ramp up what we do out there and I know
what it seems I always talk about
is like what you mitches you lack of
like oh I'm going to start I have other
people making a lot of money in this
field you know and that sort of things
hey we do we have to have that passion
we got to be able to love what we're
doing so when you are eating the beads
of the makeup let's french fries and
that sort of thing you know you're able
to realize wow you know this is what I'm
doing it I'm going to be here tomorrow
doing it in the next day doing it
everything you know and part of that is
going out when it create as much value
for your clients or the people that are
working with and I think when you have
that understanding that balance you know
that's what helps like you said propel
you to eat a success and everything yeah
I mean you may look at somebody on
YouTube and say well I want a baby tube
star I want to be like Josh right I want
to have my channel I want to be rocking
it josh is killing it that's the way to
make money I'm gonna go and be YouTube
star too well it took me eight hundred
videos on my channel before I wasn't
embarrassed for that by what i was
making like maybe you got her concert
but me man 800 videos before I wasn't
embarrassed by what I was putting out
there and you know if you don't love
that stuff you're gonna quit like
there's no what are you gonna make 800
videos there's no way you're gonna keep
doing it for years and sucking at it and
slowly getting better and improving and
hitting road block after road block
unless you're Aaron love it so it's
super important Josh makes it look easy
but it's not I'm like you manage like
you just got you just got in your head
and you have to keep doing it it's I
know you shoot them in your and it was
just 40 but I just reshoot it or just
keep redoing it so yeah you know at
least it's partially good and you can
put it out and then just keep pushing if
you push it and keep pushing so but no
that's really cool um so you kind of
mentioned it earlier like hey you know I
have we had a biotech company and it
just wasn't going and we were able to
just take it installed out you know and
make you know make some money what was
that you know I guess what was that key
on what was that indicator and I you
said you modeled you know Microsoft to
me but what
maybe I cool transition and you kind of
keep sticking with it yeah so the two
things that really helped me one was was
modeling success and just having having
that strategy that I thought I thought I
had tried everything right like
everything I had tried up to that point
I had been successful at in in school
and sports what I knew if I work harder
at it I get results and here I was
working my ass off and just sucking hard
at my business and and that mall and
success help help me so when we had that
first strategy I applied it to
everything in my business so we're
looking at well what are we going to use
for our next marketing campaign let's go
model successful marketing campaigns see
what we can learn from that it's awesome
so that was one and the other was my own
limiting beliefs oh ok I was selling to
people who were you know three times my
age at phd's you know were professors
and doctors and I thought I'm too young
you know I don't know I'm not a
scientist and everyone skies was my
worst subject in school and and I was
afraid to talk to them and uh and it
came across like I was I had no
confidence sure it was until I realized
that you know what I'm offering has real
value like I can help them and they
don't care what my degree is as long as
I can provide value to them and we're
willing position for me and that switch
in my head just knowing that I can
actually help these guys give me so much
more confidence and help me land so much
more business wow that's amazing Eddie
and you know had you especially with
entrepreneurs you know failure and
limiting beliefs are there to the major
URLs that you know it's hard for people
like overcome an Oreo push past and you
know with the limiting beliefs what were
some steps that you took to kind of
break you through those barriers I mean
I think that's a phenomenal piece that
people really need to understand here
yeah and I still have them by the way
and we all do right every time I've made
a significant growth in my life for my
business is because I've shattered a
limiting belief yes and it may be you
know my parents were Tantra printer so
so I could say well I don't have any
entrepreneurs in my
family so I can't be successful or I
don't have a rich uncle jim who can
support which won't be successful or I
didn't get a university education which
I did but a lot of people would say that
because I don't have that I'm not
successful and check we create these
stories in our heads and and it's and
they're so ingrained that we we don't
even notice them and what really helped
me get past them was reading the stories
of famous entrepreneurs so that mall in
success looking at how they started and
a lot of times these guys came from
nothing like nothing broke other side of
the tracks no education a lot of times
it came from absolutely nothing and they
achieved monumental success and if you
do that why am I with way more resources
and ideas and energy than he was why am
i sucking so hard uh and and it's just
it's limits a limited personal belief
and so look at those stories really
helped me break through cool I think
that's an excellent advice is just you
don't be able to take those stories of
other people and apply it what they'd
use you know through your whole model a
success formula to push through those
barriers everything that you haven't i
know for me one of the things that I've
always tried to do since I was one of
the very first books i read was a
limited power with tony robbins when i
was 14 and so you know in that and just
working on and constantly applying it
through my life just you know all those
pieces and parts you know and i still
get hung up I mean there's times like
mad you know just why is this person
more successful or why does this and you
start to compare yourself and and then
you got to just take that step back and
realize okay I can be whatever I want to
be from a level of success that I define
as well as you know i'm the only person
holding myself back and i know a lot of
entrepreneurs they get in front of
themselves and they're the ones hey
you're the one that's holding yourself
back and you just kind of let go and
you'll just really get out there and go
after it oh yeah i know most people
they'll blame others right they'll say
well i didn't get this because of the
economy or because of that client or
because of my parents or whatever we're
in charge man and when you
recognize that you start to make changes
but if you don't then you stay on your
current track and you never experienced
that significant growth yeah that later
I was looking at something earlier there
was actually a pretty cool thing I
jotted down it was like the ownership
mindset is you got to own your own
thoughts on your own actions and own
your results that's all up to you I like
it so uh awesome what real quick we have
to wrap up here in a minute but luckily
hear what you said you're working on a
book and you know when's it coming out
and how can I help you with that ah
details are still being worked on with
just under a contract so I don't have
too much to share but I guess get were
to learn more about me they can check
out the youtube channel that's probably
the easiest way its modeling the Masters
on YouTube okay awesome well I was
really excited to have you on the show
and you were able to really share some
awesome insights and you know looking
forward to pushing this content out
there and being able to have you know
the wit nation audience you'll really
take a look at it and learn whoever it
is and grab those nuggets and applying
them at their own life so thanks again
for coming on the show Evan and I really
appreciate your time today no problem at
any time cool i'm josh dover you're
watching making bank on the whatever it
takes network make it an awesome day
cool we're good